[Music]
hey you guys here we are again ooh look
we're like all pink and it's kind of
dark in here what the hell well i think
my little light over there isn't on yeah
so that's kind of why that's the damn uh
what you call it the red curtains red
curtains i know it looks like a dark
room yeah this this lighting system is
not the ideal we need to get some more
bounce on this
well you know i just i haven't had time
to so okay you know we'll get around to
it eventually uh but yeah so i know it's
like later than we usually do a matinee
but we were talking today about well you
know like for the matinee shows maybe we
shouldn't worry too much about
doing them at a specific or the same
time every day like maybe we should just
do them when we can get around to do
them because we've been out like we're
out uh pretty much all day today so we
just got back and
we saw another movie this morning too we
saw venom so we'll be talking about that
one tomorrow but we actually saw
the new james bond film
yesterday and uh
i quite enjoyed it
you know
hello i thought it was good yeah
i'm talking to the landlord
[Laughter]
all right well you should have that
before i started well
yeah
but uh yeah it's
i looked up how long it was because
remember i said it's kind of long but it
didn't really seem all that long because
i was kind of because i was into it uh
it was two hours and 43 minutes
so almost three hours oh i didn't
realize that i thought it was only about
two minutes
two minutes
two hours yeah no it was almost three
hours like i said i knew it was long
just because i wasn't thinking about
like when we were watching it but we
went to like the early like the first
showing i think it was at 10 45 in the
morning
and then so we watched and i was like
wow that was actually pretty good that
was like better than i was expecting and
um then like tom's like oh my god it's
like two o'clock in the afternoon and i
was just kind of like holy crap how long
was that movie like i didn't really
think about it because
we uh you know because we went to
absolution last night too so i'm still
like really really
really tired man i feel like i just
haven't got any sleep like in the last
four days or something
yeah and i was just like i mean we went
to absolution last night for a few hours
it was cool we saw a starry night and a
few other bands and stuff but it's just
like the whole time i was like oh my god
i was like i could barely keep my eyes
open
like the whole time but uh but yeah so
like i said we went and saw it in uh
dolby
and i can't
i don't know i kind of feel like we
can't really spoil it i mean this is the
last uh daniel craig bond movie
uh so you know that they're gonna like
end it it's gonna be like you know with
the finality and everything and i
actually kind of i really liked the way
they ended it to be honest with you i
think that everything got wrapped up in
the movie everything got ready yeah they
didn't leave anything hanging or
anything like that which i thought was
like was was really cool they just kind
of like they they wrapped everything up
in a neat package included including all
the bad guys they wrapped up spectre
they wrapped up a bunch of [ __ ] they
wrapped up [ __ ] the [ __ ] that was
happening at mi mi6 yeah or the mi6 and
what they called it yeah yeah
um so they didn't leave anything hanging
i kind of like the the only criticism i
would get it's not as um
it wasn't shot as pretty it's not as
pretty as the other movies in the series
you know what i'm saying in terms of
cinematography yeah well maybe okay it
was kind of like a little bit more like
grungy looking and not it didn't have
like these big it did have like some big
sweeping vistas and it does go to a lot
of places like there's they go to italy
and they get a um they go to cuba and
they go like some other places too but i
just feel like it wasn't as cause you
know how you know casino royale and
stuff like that had these big like
sweeping vistas of like all these like
luxurious locations and this had like a
little bit of that but the cinematic you
could tell that it was a different
cinematographer that's all i'm going to
say but that's it wasn't really like it
that didn't really bother me but it was
just something that i noticed because
the themes the theme song really didn't
give an impression
it was a yeah it was it was a sad song
another sad one but uh but i think that
that kind of like fit
well that fit the tone of the movie i
mean because you know at the end of
spectre
um you know basically you know blofeld
got uh got thrown in prison and then
james bond was like [ __ ] this [ __ ] and
like went off with madeleine yeah and so
that's kind of where this starts off
yeah where
you know that there's a thing about with
some flashbacks too yeah it starts off
with a flashback which actually i really
likes that opening sequence cause that
was a little bit unusual for a james
bond movie it was almost like a slasher
movie like not like not exactly like a
slasher maybe but
it was sort of structured like that and
i thought that was kind of like uh
interesting and sort of different and it
was just like a flashback and then there
you know there's a bit with him and
madeline and then
you know somebody's after them and then
like it jumps ahead five years and
that's when most of the [ __ ] takes place
because uh because of that but
yeah i mean i i kind of feel like
it seems like it's doing really well
right and we went to the show we went to
the dolby showing at 10 45 in the
morning and it was almost full yeah
which i was like really surprised we had
to sit in the very very front row
it's a strong movie it's actually you
know the whole bond series
with craig is pretty strong five pretty
strong movies um they weren't all
exactly the same
this one was up towards the top though i
think it was one of my favorite ones um
it had
it had a lot of um
easter eggs and uh
having to do with bond i mean you look
at you go into mi6 and you look on the
walls and you see all the m's
all right you see
judy dench m and then you see the other
m's from back of the sean connery days
uh
just uh
it
instead of it is like kind of a regular
daniel bond excuse me uh daniel craig
james bond uh movie where it is gritty
but they kind of throw in
a couple of things in there that might
have homaged
bond [ __ ] from the roger moore era
where it was kind of [ __ ] bizarre but
it did make sense it was kind of cheesy
but bizarre at the same time because
blowfit was [ __ ] crazy he did [ __ ]
[ __ ] he was weird you know
and spectre was a [ __ ] criminal
organization that kind of had a
kind of like a gothic flair for [ __ ]
the macabre you know
and some weird [ __ ] happened with that
uh
[ __ ] i don't want to spoil it you know
this is non-spoilers they're just saying
it's it's a good flick um some [ __ ]
happens that it's like what the [ __ ] the
gadgetry and gizmo type [ __ ] happens
kind of like you know
like a roger moore movie there's just
homage in it
you know yeah it's not and it's funny
because this movie even though it's
overall like quite sad yeah um you know
there's a lot of humor that there's a
lot of humor in it i was like surprised
not you know not over the top but just
kind of like there's some very dry humor
in there which i actually really liked
and kind of appreciated i'd say in
casino royale or maybe like skyfall that
probably wouldn't
have
done some of the homages that this one
yeah did but it did get away with it um
okay the example i'm talking about is
that
james bond has this like in
aston martin right it's it's been
totally modified by his department over
the years and in one scene and they show
it in the trailer so you know i'm not
spoiling it the headlights move down and
a couple of [ __ ] miniguns come out
and he starts
cutting donuts [ __ ] firing off them
[ __ ] miniguns
and killing all these guys who had
surround the car
it looked cool on film and that was like
some james bond [ __ ] from
from from from a [ __ ] roger moore
movie
but anybody who's got any sense who
knows anything about things like
military weapons and [ __ ] miniguns
and [ __ ] not only could those guns not
fit in that car the amount of ammo that
he fired off couldn't have fit in that
car
but don't spoil everyone's vehicle yeah
but it just you know it was
supposed to be no
they would have done that in a roger
moore movie no problem that was a james
bond thing they probably wouldn't have
done that in they didn't do that that
kind of [ __ ] in uh
casino royale then they they would have
done it probably in skyfall yeah but
they got away with they were trying to
be restrained in a lot of those
in this one they went nah [ __ ] it let's
go james bond full james bond you know
well they were trying to give like uh
like you said they were trying to tip
the hat to the whole series the whole
series right and
not make it like cheesy roger moore or
80s stuff but just kind of like homaging
that because they're kind of it's like a
culmination yeah you know it's the last
daniel crazy
so even though like i said overall it's
actually quite a sad film yeah you know
a lot of bad [ __ ] happens in it but it
does have a little bit of levity and it
does have a little bit of
like you said homage to the to the older
thing where there's more emphasis on
gadgets there's more you know like stuff
with the car and the thing with the
eyeball and all that kind of stuff um
you know where it was just kind of like
i don't want to say goofy because that's
over
overstating it but it was fantasy yeah
it's just more like fantasy fun things
which like i said i think a lot of
people that are into the james bond
movies i think that's what they like
about that yeah some people do is that
they're kind of like escapism yes in a
lot of ways they through
that segment a bone and it worked it
worked good yeah you know i love the
movie uh trying to think what else they
did that was different
oh uh
yeah i remember i had something in mind
and it slipped my mind [ __ ] what was it
that they did
i mean i was thinking like uh with humor
and everything like that
uh i really liked that sequence with uh
anna de armas that took place in cuba
yeah where she was
she just had she had three weeks
training yeah but didn't believe that
i think being a bimbo was her cover
yeah
that's not that's not who she really was
that was a funny thing yeah that was
that was and that was directly out of
the [ __ ] roger moore type series yeah
um
what i was going to say is is that the
the trailers to this movie were very
deceptive i didn't like a lot of the
trailers especially earlier on it would
it looked like the movie was going to be
uh
it was going to be kind of emphasizing
that uh
the the [ __ ] daniel craig was [ __ ]
old and over the hill and that he
[ __ ] was all broken down and [ __ ] and
they showed clips of him looking kind of
bad in the first few trailers it's not
how he looks in the movie when you see
it though some of some of those scenes
are in it
but he's just been beaten up a couple
times you know when when you see him
like that and it's just
they they make it known early on in the
movie that yeah he's probably pushing 60
now i don't know how old he really is um
what is he
57 i have no idea maybe
now they show him he's in good shape
he's in really good shape it's [ __ ]
it's not really
it's not really biologically possible
for a
guy his age to have that physique and
not have of course [ __ ]
assistance you know from from the secret
sauce
but uh
no he does all kinds of [ __ ] [ __ ] he
does get beat up and get hurt
but he does make it
well the thing about it too is i kind of
feel like even going back to skyfall
um
you know the the the theme of a lot of
skyfall spectre like a thread that was
running through there was that you know
he's getting old he doesn't really want
to do it anymore yeah he's getting
pretty beat up and he's yeah and he's
kind of losing his enthusiasm for it so
even though like in this one obviously
he's been retired for like five years
and then he comes back because there's
you know obviously another big you know
super billion super villain like plot
that he has to help
at first he starts working with the cia
right and then like you know they kind
of reinstate him laughing after that
yeah there's a double agent in this for
a while yeah but it's like so they don't
show so even though he's been retired
for five years they don't show him like
oh he has to get back into training or
anything like that but i didn't mind
that because they did that in skyfall
yeah like he'd been out for a long time
and then he showed he came back and he
didn't have a [ __ ] together and it took
him a long time to get back into shape
so i was just kind of like i felt like
they've they've done that already so
they didn't have to do it like yeah he's
been retired for five years and he came
back and you know was fine but it's like
you know yeah well they uh
they show early on that he's
still has his physicality he was living
out on the island and he was still
keeping his [ __ ] fit yeah and he still
had weapons and [ __ ] [ __ ] that he wasn't
supposed to yeah he wasn't laying around
on the sofa eating ding-dongs no he was
living in the wild
and he was all he looked like jamaica
you know he was out fishing fishing and
hanging out in the club scene
and uh one of the first thing that
happens to him is he gets blown up
that [ __ ] him up yeah
and then some guys tried to run him over
when he's on a little narrow bridge that
was down somewhere in greece wasn't it
that was italy italy yeah
and he jumps they show this in the
previews he [ __ ] dives off the side
of this damn bridge to get out of the
way he's hanging onto a car
and grabs a cable and pulls it down and
uses it to slow himself down but he
smacks into the side of the bridge
supports and [ __ ] him up
and he was about 20 feet off the ground
and [ __ ] falls boo [ __ ] knocks his
ass out it's all kinds of [ __ ]
so yeah they let you know early on that
he he's still [ __ ] ready you know he
can do his [ __ ]
but it is catching up with him you know
which it would
you kind of want to stop it
but he keeps getting sucked back into it
uh another good thing that they did is
that they brought back my [ __ ] uh one
of my favorite characters they brought
back felix
yeah he's not in all of the [ __ ] new
bond movies he's he's he's in yeah he's
the cia guy he's a cia guy yeah and he's
kind of burned out too
uh he knows that [ __ ] the cia is not
always cracked up to be in the [ __ ]
that what they're doing is [ __ ] he
doesn't really believe it because they
were actually in one movie they were
coming they were going after bond over
[ __ ] some false [ __ ] and he let
him go and he let him go because he was
[ __ ]
but uh he's in it and when he works for
the cia he's working with felix man i
[ __ ] love that part
and uh phyllis always calling him my
brother you know his
brother my brother your brother's down
at langley you know kind of [ __ ] you
know
because you know because they're trying
to
let the audience know in case they
weren't american or british that the us
and
the us and the british were allies on
the on the intel front so they worked
together
and felix also let it be know that the
americans had all the damn money
they had all the money it's a [ __ ] in
casino royale the brits were running out
of money and he goes but we got all the
money
and whatever you win just keep it we got
money
because they [ __ ] print that [ __ ]
okay
so uh yeah so they finally sealed that
they wrap up felix's [ __ ]
friendship with bond which that was that
was the perfect [ __ ] thing they
wrapped up all the things all the loose
ends yeah i can't really think of
anything from the five movies that they
left
hanging yeah i don't think they really
did no nothing was left hanging yeah
they kind of they and it was good too
because they had
you know yeah yeah he comes back for
like the the last mission and everything
like that and they had something that
was
a big even though
i guess like from a scientific viewpoint
it's not it's just on the bare side of
like baby believable um but it would you
know if if they had let it go it would
have like killed like millions and
millions of people yeah it's about so it
was like a big yeah but it's like a
nanobot kind of yeah well yeah it did
both it was nanobots and it also had a
genetic dna and i mixed in with it um it
was
i guess i could tell the problems um
the british intelligence was working on
a damn
super weapon it was a bio weapon that
had nanites and [ __ ] involved with it
and you could let this thing out and it
would specifically go after a certain
person and and it would use the general
population as carriers
so you're letting out a custom tailored
pandemic that everybody catches it but
it's harmless to them but it kills one
specific one specific person
whose genes are targeted it was i
believe it was smallpox was it not like
a weaponized smallpox no it was ebola
wasn't it ebola no i thought i'm pretty
sure it was smallpox i thought they were
talking about ebola like at the well
they started bleeding out of their faces
and [ __ ] almost melting and [ __ ] i
thought i was pretty sure it was some
kind of well it it was a mixture of a
lot of [ __ ] and nanites
yeah
well anyway uh this weapon gets stolen
by group
and they can re they want to retailer it
to [ __ ] end mankind and [ __ ]
purify their planet and [ __ ] so it is
it's it's like a eugenics dream it's a
depopulation dream
to kind of uh i guess what [ __ ]
reduce the [ __ ] earth's population
down of a manageable thing you know it's
kind of [ __ ] interesting that the
movie these movies tend to come out with
themes that are [ __ ] topically
relevant
there just might be something to what
they're talking about very malthusian
the the bad guy is ver is a malthusian
if you know what i'm talking about
malthus he thinks there's too many
people
basically he wants to be the only person
earth is getting a little too crowded
i'm just gonna wipe out everybody yeah
then i'll have all this room for myself
right now it's not so simple spectre's
involved with this [ __ ] but you'll see
you'll see what happens in spectre
um
it's good it's a good flick i liked it
i liked it as well um i you know did uh
danny rowling ghostface said did the
film seem too long no i didn't you know
what i i really didn't think that like
because i was ki i was into it and i
wasn't really
i think after it ended and we saw what
time it was i was like holy crap that
was a long movie and then when i looked
it up later i was like oh my god it was
almost three hours but it didn't really
seem like that while i was watching it i
don't know because i guess i was just
into it and it kind of went from one
thing to the next thing and i was just
kind of like oh you know what's
happening now so i don't know it didn't
bother me maybe some people like would
think it was too long but i didn't think
it was too long
um
yeah mango's saying uh did we spoil the
ending yet no but i mean
you know
it's it's the last daniel craig bond
film yeah
oh that's all i'm to say got to mention
some our regulars though we heard from
b's nest he got sick he's here he's in
there all right yeah right there yeah he
got sick he knew he'd feeling well
he's back
yeah because we we were kind of worried
i thought those mexican cops got you bro
[Laughter]
yeah mango said i wish felix had a
better ending to his story uh i thought
it was good though but it had a lot of
good stuff but it really does drag i
didn't yeah it didn't to me it didn't
really seem to drag i don't know i was i
was kind of into it um
and
like i said i'm not you you are a bigger
like uh fan of the bond movies than i am
because i mean i like them but i'm just
kind of like
you know i'm not like a super fan or
anything and i've seen like a lot of the
old ones but
it's not really like one of my favorite
franchises but
i don't know the daniel craig bond
movies i just really really i always
really like them and actually to be
honest i think i liked this one better
than
quantum of solace
and
maybe better than casino i'm not really
sure even though i will say i think i
mentioned this the other day but it's
like quantum of solace i remember seeing
that the first time and not really
caring for it but then when i saw it a
second time i liked it a lot better yeah
but i still think i like this one better
than quantum episodes i think somebody's
saying that somebody just puts 53 in
there that must be how old how old
daniel craig is in the face he looks
older than that he does well it's yeah
well it's just because he looks like
he's kind of craggy looking anyway
craggy yeah but um
no and his physique though he you know
he's he's [ __ ] looks like a young man
he looks like a [ __ ] he's been [ __ ]
he's been working out and [ __ ] on the
sauce he could tell
looks in pretty good shape actually but
uh he might need he might need a little
[ __ ] nip and a tuck there and maybe
well the thing about it is that i mean
he's 53 years old and he's been doing
these bond films for what like 15 years
and he gets the [ __ ] kicked out of him
like he gets beat up on a lot of these
like he gets hurt on every single one
uh you know what i mean and including
this one i don't remember like all the
injuries he got but he gets injured on
pretty much everyone which i think is
after because i think initially
initially if please correct me if i'm
wrong but i thought he was only going to
do three
and he hated him evidently he didn't
like doing these and then well because
because like i said he gets his ass
kicked on him and it's like you know and
he just gets hurt on every single one
and so i think he was initially supposed
to do three and then he got talked into
they said well why don't you do like one
or two more and he was like okay fine
and then like he did that but then like
this one he was just like this is
absolutely my last one i'm really really
not doing anymore but
look man you guys can people saying you
know did you spoil the ending let this
it's in the [ __ ] title
it's in the [ __ ] title he's the last
one yeah he dies
he ties him
but he goes out [ __ ] like a champ and
really there he is really there was
there was no hope for him anyway
he got so [ __ ] up that no
he didn't live yeah well yeah and like i
said like you said he goes out like a
jay like kind of saving the saving the
world yeah saving the world he went out
saving the world
[Laughter]
but the thing is that you see it coming
you know what i mean you know that
that's what's gonna happen
and uh you
he's losing everything anyway
kinda so yeah there's no turning back
he's gotta [ __ ] do it yeah so
uh yeah but no it was good
and
i think that in all the other ones they
just kind of end okay and then they show
up with a new bond
i think killing bond at the end of it
was a good idea because that way you
totally reboot and make a new james bond
a whole new universe yeah all new guy
which is what they've been doing in
memorial but it's like they never really
had the balls to end the damn store and
the series right so that i think i think
it was a brave choice to end the [ __ ]
series to give bond a [ __ ] death yeah
that way
if you liked that series of movie
there's a totally encapsulated james
bond tale it includes even what happens
to him yeah you have a one version where
if you throw that move the last movie
off in one version he just retires
you like that ending then that's the one
you can but you don't have yeah then you
don't have to watch the last one you
don't have to but yeah because that
specter at the end of spectre he just
like walks off with madeleine and he's
like yeah i'm retiring yeah bye but
retirement for bond isn't how you're
supposed to go out that's kind of like
going out like a [ __ ]
[Laughter]
bond really should die
well yeah and that's how an a die saving
the world like captain kirk
[Laughter]
[ __ ] like
that mango said
uh i think he went out like a bit of a
wimp but that's how i saw it that's just
the way you're looking at it but
he went through all that other there was
there was no other choice
yeah he really did he really he got to a
point where he just didn't really have a
choice and like you said he was kind of
[ __ ] up at the end too yeah like he
couldn't
he wasn't gonna have a normal life
anyway
yeah his life is over that's that's all
so he might as well go down go go down
with [ __ ]
with everybody and that's what he did
yeah
but you know he he [ __ ] had a bunch
of gun fights [ __ ] killed a bunch of
dudes [ __ ] shot dudes [ __ ] uh yeah
it was good he went down uh now i i
don't want to say how he died but maybe
maybe you said it's got going out like a
[ __ ] but not really
because uh it wasn't really enemy action
you'll see
yeah that's true it wasn't really enemy
action so in a way you deny the enemy of
victory so it wasn't the enemy that
killed him
see oh yeah yeah you could put it that
way too more like he killed himself
yeah because he made the choice yeah you
know yeah which that's what spock did
yeah you know
that's right [ __ ] sacrifice himself
yeah yeah he goes into the reactor spock
no spot it's too late jim
bray open it up no you'll flood us with
radiation you know
yeah
yeah he chose to sacrifice himself
it was a situation like that which is
yeah which is kind of what happened what
happened here uh mega said i did like
how he got rid of the villain no messing
about yeah yeah
try to say some [ __ ]
[Laughter]
just shut up yeah
you [ __ ] bond villains how did your
long-winded thing i think it was one of
the one of the top movies i want to see
it again i'll definitely buy it
because you have all the other ones i
have all the other ones and it it will
i think kind of the
my least favorite would probably be
spectre
but spectre isn't bad
it's not a bad movie spectre is good and
they age pretty well
my favorite is still the first one
though casino royale
i have to say that opening that opening
sequence of spectre
uh at the day of the dead festival with
like the helicopter yeah there was a lot
of good stuff that was fantastic and
when he was like running over the
[ __ ] tops of the buildings the
buildings are collapsing and [ __ ] that
was great there was none of the movies
are bad even you know yeah there's good
[ __ ] in all of them even spectre was a
[ __ ] good movie it's just i would say
i think it i don't know it's hard to say
it's hard to say
and some people say well quantum solids
but no i i quantum of solace i think is
one of my favorite ones like i said i
liked it better the second time i
watched it i didn't like it the first
time i watched it i just couldn't get
into it yeah i don't i don't know why i
just kind of thought it was like i don't
know it was kind of boring or i could i
just couldn't like uh get into the story
but then when i watched it the second
time after i'd seen the later ones i
liked it a lot better
and um
i i think they had to kill craig off
they just they had to because
had they continued to make movies it
just would have gone down the roger
moore uh
channels of him just
getting older and older and more
ridiculous and [ __ ] more pretty boy
and [ __ ] less combat effect he's like
he's like 90 years old and he's like
pursuing these like 20 year old
and it would have started looking really
weird some kind of [ __ ] old man he's
there
yeah
he has like these 18 year old girls
going ooh you're supposed to mr
[ __ ] 250 pound [ __ ] wrestlers and
[ __ ]
you know he's doing it with like star
trek style karate chops
he's shouting the [ __ ] out of a
[ __ ] hey it works for captain
kirk
yeah yeah he he knows all this special
like
[Laughter]
[Music]
man i wish i wish uh i wish kirk would
teach me some of those moves you could
just go like that and it like [ __ ]
knocks a [ __ ] i once saw kurt
[ __ ] make his fist out of two hands
and hit a [ __ ] in the back and
it knocked him out yeah he did that a
lot i kind of feel like he was always
the [ __ ] was that
it's like normally people would be like
what the [ __ ] yeah
i'd like to see a dude try that
i bet you sometime in the 60s dudes were
fighting at a bar where there's some
[ __ ] if i could try that on another
dude
that would work that dude looked at him
and just beat the [ __ ]
[Laughter]
yes i can't even see
i can't even see even if you were like
really really strong i don't really see
how that
would well you got one fist right now
you got two
okay so obviously that's [ __ ] right
right in the back right in the center of
the back
knocks him out
it's reversed it's a vulcan technique
yeah everybody knows that there's like
this really special place like right in
the middle of your back and if you hit
it just right you don't have to you can
just touch it yeah yeah right
yeah and it knocks the person yeah
the focus is not true
the ball can still fall off [ __ ]
right yeah yeah again yeah if there's a
[ __ ] spot could teach me that [ __ ]
too you just kind of go up and go like
that and they're just like
yeah man i wish i could [ __ ] learn
all that stuff
uh yeah danny rowling ghostface
hopefully there's a new bond video game
them games are always good actually
there's a need to be a new one what they
need to do is remaster and re-release
[ __ ] golden eye off n64 i kind of
feel like goldeneye was sort of like
everybody's favorite james bond tie-in
video game i loved it man when that
thing first came out even with that
[ __ ] sucky ass n64 controller back in
the 90s it only had one joystick on it
you could still get good with it and
you've had to press the [ __ ] left
trigger button to [ __ ] aim and then
the crosshairs would come up and you
could strafe right and left it was a
weird way of doing it i don't know why i
just didn't put two joysticks they
weren't thinking
but um
no
goldeneye n64 was like one of the
[ __ ] best
first person shooters of all times
there's just
something about it in its era the
[ __ ] the way it looked to the ai
the way the dudes reacted when you shot
them if you shouted in the nuts you go
oh and jump up and down sometimes oh my
balls yeah
[Laughter]
shot him into need react and it was all
motion capture stuff
it looked good and had really good music
for the time and it just you weren't
really sure what was possible what was
going to happen you tried to make sense
out of certain things you'd shoot office
furniture and it would [ __ ] blow up
you shoot off his desk if you shot it
for too long you just go boom [ __ ] this
desk yeah like pieces of it disappeared
you shoot those pieces and they
disappear
[ __ ] your copier yeah
[Laughter]
yeah you're running around in the
[ __ ] russian
siberian [ __ ] missile silo base or
whatever and all these towers and
picking up the clubs they couldn't use
the actual
trademark they weren't sure if you could
use the trademark names for a lot of
these weapons so they had to rename them
right you know what i mean there was all
these weird names for like dude that's a
[ __ ] cz scorpion but they're calling
it a club
you know and then they [ __ ]
i think they called the ak something or
else and
it's a scorpion yeah they just they just
scorpion gun yeah
that's what it is can i say that
the trailers that we saw before
uh no time to die and the trailers that
we saw before venom which we saw today
and we'll talk about it tomorrow venom
was good uh yeah we'll talk about venom
tomorrow yeah um i think every single
trailer we saw looked like something i
wanted to say yeah there's a lot of good
movies that's kind of crazy the new dune
trailer we saw looked [ __ ] up yeah we
saw the new dune trailer we saw like i
said uh one night in soho which i'm very
excited about uh halloween kills that
actually looks pretty good um you know
so that starts next week i think
uh house of gucci the new ridley yeah
movie that actually looks really good
adam driver yeah adam driver and lady
gaga